hey everybody my name is roger craig
smith and we are going to break down my
most iconic roles which for a guy with
really bad self-esteem is just sort of
weird to even use the term iconic
i guess just roles that i've done that
you may have heard of
feels better to me but most iconic roles
we'll go with that
it's fine it's not my show
i know i caught yours
ah batman i've used the word surreal so
many times to describe what that was
like but
uh getting the call that you got cast as
the voice of batman in an upcoming game
is both exhilarating and
scary as all get out because you know
that kevin conroy has established this
character
so much in the animated world in the
interactive world
every decision you've ever made ends
with death and misery
and that so many other people have lent
their voice to this character before you
that it's gonna be like what a cool
feather in your cap from a career
perspective
but also man oh man oh man i hope that i
do this justice
to the point where fans will understand
what we were attempting to do with this
particular project that kind of thing
but so the interesting part about
sort of taking on the role and and even
going through the
audition process was how how
much we kind of tried to mess with the
voice print
because of the fact that so many sort of
versions of batman have existed
so the idea that we were going to just
do a
certain delivery style might not
have worked well so we spent a
considerable amount of time i would say
the first week
of sessions we really tried to to to
kind of dial in
what version of batman we wanted to kind
of emulate because obviously you've got
like the christian bale version and we
kind of even toyed around with a little
more throaty gravelly kind of stuff
if i get him to you can you get him to
talk what you will hear
in the game there's moments when he
picks joker up and says you know
how many lives did you just take how
many lives did you just take
none it sprinkles in a little bit of
that version of it because we wanted it
to be a familiar
batman but also unique to this origin
story
so it was it was interesting to kind of
go through that process it was like in
the audition process you're
you're trying different things you're
you're you know
taking different approaches to how you
would deliver a certain line trying to
give them variations on it
and be malleable um but yeah we we
clearly took our time on that first week
i just recall us
trying to go down a few different paths
as far as
which version we were going to go with
and we finally settled on something that
would that would make
really good sense for it being since
it's an origin story
this is where we can understand that
this is
this version of batman will be what
kevin
and with troy's performance as joker
what mark had established as the joker
that that we go okay
okay i can see where these these
characters would become
those characters that we know especially
in the arkham universe so
i work where i step into the booth
and the director is gonna tell me
exactly what they're going for
and that can be even with a legacy
character
um you know i'm a hired gun in reality
so
i'm not gonna step in and go here's this
version of this character that i do the
way that i do
in comparison to say arkham origins to
batman unlimited that would have been a
too aggressive version of batman for
something that was more family friendly
or when it comes to uh obviously
superman red sun
spoiler alert very different version of
batman that i've ever played for a
number of different reasons you got the
accent for one
now she's as obedient to me as those
poor mindjack dissidents are to you
but also dark it's a dark version of
batman that was
kind of cool i loved that moment it
doesn't matter what character i've done
or how many times i've done it when i
step under the booth
um whoever's directing uh and whoever's
behind the the production of it
it's going to be a collaborative effort
for us to figure out what version of
this character we want to conjure up
and a lot of things can influence that
so i just try to be as as ready for
anything as possible
um while also speaking up if i feel like
this feels
out of character you know that both uh
i've always said you know there's this
box that these characters sort of live
in
that you can play around only so much
before it starts to really kind of feel
like
no that just doesn't feel doesn't feel
right for the character and that's where
maybe i would
take a stand if i felt like we were
doing anything like that but with these
types of characters it's so rare that
you would have somebody do
anything like that you might have
somebody do that for like a marketing
you know aspect or somebody who doesn't
understand the
the way that a lot of us covet these
characters um
but no in in everything i've been a part
of it's always just a big collaborative
effort on the the part of the production
staff director
myself we we work together to figure out
what version of this character we're
going to do in that given moment
there is one thing i do know i have a
job to do
and i'm gonna see it through ah
chris redfield i need an egg
you know what's funny is i look back on
on resident evil 5 i think one of
my favorite moments uh was working with
uh with stephanie shay and liam o'brien
who were directing me on this project
and liam happened to be on the other
side of the glass in one of these
sessions
and i this was arguably this was going
to be the first big
video game role i had ever booked and i
didn't
i honestly hadn't had too much
experience with the whole resident evil
series leading up to that
and uh all of a sudden it's like i'm in
this session with liam
and and i just kind of paused and i was
like
like there's gonna be like there's gonna
be a lot of attention on this game huh
like a lot of people like the resident
evil series of games and he just was
he starts laughing he goes yeah there's
probably gonna be a few people checking
this one out because i think i was like
oh that's cool okay
yeah i was like yeah i guess uh yeah
it's gonna be interesting
that whole thing was such a like that
was one of the first like
big long form facial motion capture jobs
that i'd done it was kind of early on in
some of that facial motion capture
technology so we were still using glue
and the little reflective dots and all
that stuff so there was a long process
involved
getting him on and all that um and they
would constantly fall off and you were
being asked to make big facial
expressions which was kind of like
trying to finesse the
the facial movements for the data that
they needed for the computer versus
delivering a performance because you
don't want every everything to sound
like this
it's funny whenever i see things like
this i always go back to the experience
that i had
being in the booth working with the
people that i worked with and the the
sort of friendships and the bonds that
are created
in those moments um and so i just think
i
think back to a lot of really fond
memories of
goofing off with stephanie and liam in
the booth and
and having a good time uh making art and
knowing that what we were gonna do was
hopefully gonna be received well
um but yeah chris was just like what a
cool what a cool thing to be able to be
a part of and
and to attempt to do outlandish sort of
stories and punching boulders and all
that good stuff
[Music]
yeah it was a really cool really cool
role and just i need an egg
you know like getting to say that over
and over and over again you know in that
crisp voice give me an egg use this
i need an egg it never gets old if if
i'm
at the supermarket and i go in for eggs
i don't just say like where are your
eggs
i gotta go up to somebody go like i need
an give me an egg you know
that's the way you do it that and
pressing the b button over and over
again so i could hear uh shiva
constantly saying my name raja
that never got old for me personally
roja
what it's my name roger yeah
say it again all right shabba raja yeah
foreign
show some respect respect ah
yes angio day forensi um ends you out of
tour
de da da friends uh ezio yeah
this is another one of those roles where
i just think back to the camaraderie
the the joy of getting to
work with people that i became good
friends with
as a result of being introduced to this
character this franchise
the project this was a nice one for me
because there was no
version of well you're not my ezio
there wasn't a he was uh a brand new
character
that we were getting a chance to kind of
create from scratch
and uh and there were there were genuine
moments where i was given a chance to
try to really connect with things and to
deliver lines in a way that i would like
to try to
do something to bring about an element
of heart to the character that was
uh rare no i can't ask you to sacrifice
your children
nobody's sacrificing anything go get
them back for me
see like i said earlier with with like a
character like a batman or
or a sonic there's there's certain
things you do that you feel like well
this would be
canon or this would be in character this
this makes sense to this version of the
character but
you can't go too far beyond it whereas
with a new character you're kind of
establishing it
um and so i don't know that it's so much
of a challenge
with a new character as it is just a at
least a unique opportunity
to sort of create and set those to
create that box
by the time you're done with about a
week's worth of recording and you're
well into the storyline
you kind of got a an idea of where you
want to push the character before it
starts to feel unnatural or too much or
too forced or too silly
or too aggressive or whatever it might
be and it sort of kind of takes a life
of its own takes on a life of its own as
a as this weird sort of like audible
organic thing
um but but i i don't know that it's
necessarily a challenge with a new
character
other than you you have a little bit
more creative freedom
um but with great freedom comes great
responsibility
hey guys what's going on you having a
party or something
surprised
[Music]
ah you guys aha
this guy the blue hedgehog how do you
not after 10 years you know
always hold a very special place in your
heart for for something that is so
iconic in gaming i always laugh in my
career and say like i'm only as good as
anything you've ever heard of so if
you're
on a plane and somebody says you know
what do you do and if you even bother
answering truthfully
then say oh a voice actor you know
voices for cartoons and games and stuff
like that
um it doesn't matter the age range of
the person it used to be that it was
like oh i'd throw out you know
some random show that i narrated or did
stuff like that and trying to think
what's the broadest audience that would
and if i say sonic the hedgehog people
go
oh of all ages all backgrounds
everybody's kind of heard of the
characters seen the character familiar
with it so
to get to be that voice is it's an
absolute honor
you guys have your work cut out for you
an adventure's no fun if it's too easy
it was kind of funny in me thinking like
man if i got this that would be another
kind of crazy feather in your cap kind
of thing going like yeah this is neat
you're gonna go from
you know this uh loverboy assassin
character from history
to you know the boulder punching you
know badass guy
to all of a sudden this really cool
iconic you know representation of gaming
uh and as as well as also doing
something that was family friendly that
you knew would be
really hitting a very wide audience as a
result of that because arguably some of
these other games are
for a more mature audience whereas this
is like it can be
uh it can be for anybody so uh and it
was more fun too
in the sense that that this unlike those
other roles
unlike batman unlike chris redfield or
ezio
this was a chance for me to kind of tap
into the
comedic background that i had and get to
to sort of like you know be funny and
silly
which is uh usually my go-to which is
why i can't believe
i've been able to voice things like you
know ezio or batman or that kind of
thing but
um no this is that was another reason
why it was so much fun kind of stepping
into something like this and getting to
play around and have fun and be snarky
and
and
smart alecky and uh yeah it's okay i got
you
you know i know cpr i mean i mean if you
didn't want me to do
that i mean you but you'd be dying
except you know i need to save you
but i am a gentleman contrary to what
people say ah
mirage good old mirage uh that one
okay so here's one where you go i don't
i don't even know
who would have thought i mean i had no
clue what i was stepping into
what i was getting myself involved with
i knew so very little about the project
i mean obviously this was like a
is this titanfall is this a another
version of titanfall or what do we do in
here you know
are these the pilots in the mechs like
what and and because
gaming companies will often be cryptic
and and uh rightfully so
and and try to you know sort of protect
as much of their intellectual property
as possible even when they're
in the middle of a production then all
of a sudden i remember doing the trailer
recorded voiceover for all the lines and
the game and all that stuff and then i
just sort of
kind of forgot about it but i remember
thinking and i've told the story
uh our the director was uh we were on a
lunch break
and um uh the director drew you know
i was just kind of picking his brain
like so when you guys uh what are you
hoping this thing's gonna be done
and he's like oh january and i think
this was like october or november
and i was in my mind i'm like okay wow
you're going to turn this around in a
very short period of time like like
good luck with that and then he was
explaining like yeah we're just going to
drop it i'm just going to drop the
trailer the game
everything's going to be free to play
and it's all coming out on the same day
and i was thinking
wow okay that's that's crazy that's like
who does that now why do why don't we
you know i mean like man you know you
got to tease it you got to get your
hashtags built up you get all this
and so all that happened we're done move
on you know three months later i'm i'm
i think it was the night of super bowl
or the monday after super bowl i think
it was and all of a sudden i started
getting these text messages from friends
going you're in this
game you're in this new game i'm like
which game you know like because you got
to be careful when you answer questions
like that because you don't want to say
like
oh yeah the new star wars game yeah i'm
totally in it you know like oh
um and so uh so i get these text
messages and i'm like
what game and they're like i don't know
this apex legends game and we often work
under code names when we do these
projects so i
i hadn't known of it being called apex
legends
or didn't recall that that was the
official name of it and all of a sudden
it's like
all these text messages start pointing
and people go like dude this game's
insane like this is awesome you're in
that that's you right you're the
you're the hologram dude i'm like yeah
yeah that's yeah yeah so i
got it fired it up played it died 10
times in a row in my first like you know
in my first 10 games and uh and was like
i'm horrible at this game
you know the the game's going fast um
but all of a sudden it just exploded and
became this thing
and all of us uh that get to be involved
with this
cast we have so much fun getting to be a
part of the fan base the community
that's been created as a result of the
incredibly awesome writing and the
production value of the game
and who'd have thought but it's it's so
neat to be a part of something like this
and watch it again
from the ground up just explode and
become a thing and then also
celebrate what that's like with the
writers
with the people who have drawn you know
drawn backgrounds who've done
character design who are creating the
next legends all that stuff it's such a
neat thing to to
to be one little tiny part in a massive
machine
of creating something as successful as
apex legends so that one i love getting
to do this guy
yeah he's he's one of my favorites for
sure
[Music]
coming up on say yes to the dress
and say yes so this is great say yes to
the dress this
this is what i was saying earlier you're
only as good as anything any
anybody's ever heard of this is one of
those shows that that i would say to
somebody
if if you're on the plane and you're
making small talk and they want to know
what you've done
i would say oh sound like the hedgehog
and maybe you'll get somebody to go no
you know like oh uh you know uh
assassin's creed nah it sounds horrible
you know it's like and then i go i
narrated uh say yes to the dress for a
really long time like oh my god you know
my and it's my favorite part is is the
macho dudes
that go like oh yeah you know you know
my
i don't watch that show but like my
girlfriend or my wife or you know it's
like
my mom my sister whatever you like they
love it you know that kind of thing
but you know i don't watch the show hey
what's up with randy every time he says
that like you know a bride looks fanta
and you're like oh don't watch the show
much right
so this is this is one of those things
it was kind of cool to be a part of a
of a series that i thought always had
like a lot of heart and i thought they
were telling some really neat stories
it was nice to just be the guy that was
just you know meanwhile across the salon
before hitting the sales floor lori
schools the staff on how to handle
brides who need to find a dress in a
hurry today
it was a bit of a challenge every now
and then where it was like you know i
was flying blind i was just given a
script
with with lines and thank goodness there
was a producer on the phone because
i've always made the joke you know the
line might be you know
meanwhile across the salon you know
bride samantha
is wishing that grant you know her
grandmother could be here for this
special moment
and i would have to say like okay
there's a couple different ways i could
deliver this line because if grandma
is stuck in traffic trying to find
parking right now it's a very different
setup than if grandma is in heaven
and missing out on this kind of it's
like you know there's two different ways
to deliver that line
um but but really fond memories and i i
just think it's such a neat thing it's
it's like again when i get to say like i
voiced batman
and say yes to the dress or you know
i've always sonic the hedgehog and ezio
aditore stuff like that
it's just uh those are those surreal
pinch me moments where you're like yeah
it's kind of a neat thing
that a ton of people have seen that
series it continues to this day
it lives on and reruns and people still
text me you know i've done
really neat little things for very close
friends of mine where i've
i've recorded you know a mock narration
uh of the of the dress selection process
for friends of mine and had fun doing
that um
yeah i'm a very fortunate human being to
have been a part of so many incredible
projects and of course say us to the
dress is
is one of those so yeah it's a believe
it or not i hold
a hold a fun place in my heart for say
yes to the dress as well
hey everybody thank you so much for
revisiting some of those most
iconic roles with me roger craig smith
voice actor who i guarantee you is not
going to watch this video
and just really cringe at the fact that
chest hair is exposed
i this is so unflattering so you're
welcome
everyone follow me on social media if
you want at roger craig smith
i i i gotta go i gotta go buy a new
shirt
this i'm not gonna i'm gonna lose sleep
over this you guys
hope you're happy roger yeah
[Music]